[Applause]
and you guys can all hear me okay I know
this guy can right here boy this guy's
ears are so big he's laughing at jokes
from the yuk-yuk Club all the way on the
other side of town and you sir you're
doing okay you get enough to eat thank
you sir folks I'm sorry I'm gonna get
everybody tonight I'm gonna get nobody
is safe I'm getting everybody except for
you sir I'm gonna leave you alone
just like your date did tonight okay who
is next who is next
hey ma'am I get it you have breasts okay
look at this chick her cleavage is
giving the Grand Canyon an inferiority
complex who's talking right now yeah hey
man pink shirt you got on there Wow
where'd you get that queer t-shirts calm
oh yeah ya know hey yeah don't you worry
about that man
gloves are coming off okay right there
right there what's with the three drinks
man alcoholic much this is my [ __ ]
course it is it's your pay medication
because uh he is in pain right now
hey make fun of the what did you say
because here's the problem sir as it's
really dark in here and sorry are you
burned cuz I can't make it out thanks so
much ma'am for illuminating him thank
you that's
I appreciate that oh those burns sir I
don't know you know what look sir
there is nothing funny about you being
in a wheelchair and we call but there is
something funny about me being fat all
right all right fine fine I've got it
I've got it
I'm doing it I'm doing it I just didn't
want to go after this guy because I
didn't want him to kill me in my dreams
like like Freddy Krueger cuz he know do
you see how Freddy Krueger's his face is
burned off that's not you [ __ ] he
said he could take it that's what he
said
host this on me how do we even know if
he's crying right now
[Applause]
you just sound like an electronic side
[Applause]
you